thank you very very much
everybody for being here this afternoon
and far go any further I want to thank
congressman mike doyle and congressman
jason Altmaier our representatives in
Congress for sponsoring this event and
arranging is for us to be in this room
let me explain the Apple it's to be
eaten they're clean they're there they
haven't been doctored in any way but of
course they're there to make a statement
this is all about education it's all
about teaching and about teachers the
focus is going to be on technology and
the role of technology can play in
higher education and a particular
technology that we've developed a
Carnegie Mellon but it is not to replace
teachers teachers are still very much a
part of this and the Apple is there to
remind all of us of that but much away
we know what your busy schedules are
like you probably didn't eat lunch
either we understand that we have some
urgent problems problems related to cost
they are high and they're rising quickly
and that leads to exclusion or if not
exclusion then crushing debt that many
graduates have when they graduate the
other issue is there are simply too many
students dropping out of the higher
education system not enough achieving
graduation whatever that might be in the
program that they're in there are just
too many students not succeeding so it's
a two-edged problem and in some respects
their length President Obama called to
the White House in December a group of
university presidents another whom is
here today and I'll introduce momentary
parrot but excuse me momentarily and it
was a very interesting session one in
which the president conveyed to us his
deep concern about these issues i just
mentioned in fact he said to us in
opening this session you have no idea
how many calls letters emails we get in
the white house every day from family
is angry and concern about this issue he
challenged us to think about new ways of
approaching education he's looking for a
Productivity revolution in higher
education he wants us to think outside
of the box and these are challenges we
in higher education have to accept I was
there because i'm president of Carnegie
Mellon University and Carnegie Mellon
has been a leader in developing
technology for education that we think
can be an important part of the response
to this urgent problem that we face the
key to our approach is what we call
learning science this in effect is a new
field that's come out of many decades of
research at Carnegie Mellon and
elsewhere that brings together cognitive
psychology with computer science it's a
very powerful combination and one that
we think can help to transform higher
education on the back of the program is
a timeline that shows you the origins of
this how developed over the years to the
point that we're at today let me
acknowledge the support of many sponsors
but in particular and most recently the
National Science Foundation which has
been a key supporter of ours and
significantly the supporter of the
Pittsburgh science of learning center I
said it's time for a Productivity
revolution actually the president said
it's time for productivity revolution
and I'm just mimicking his words this is
in some respect it's time for higher
education as a sector the think of
itself no different from other sectors
that have seen great gains in
productivity there are some good reasons
why productivity gains are hard in
higher education I won't bore you with
the economic argument about that but
it's time for us to eat our own cooking
if I can put it that way and we have
developed techniques and tools and
you're about to hear about one of them
technology can be a vehicle
to attack this problem but i want to
emphasize it's not the answer in and of
itself the key to the power of the open
learning initiative then we're going to
be telling you about is its grounding in
very solid scientific principles about
how children learn about how people
learn learning is a cognitive process
and bring together the insights from
that cognitive science with computer
science that's the key it's also the
case that by adopting these kinds of
methods we then have basically real-time
data at the finest grain about how
students are learning in in real time we
also have data that we can use to
improve the basic science the learning
science that undergirds these
technologies this is a new idea in one
that we've never had before but simply
put and I'm going to get off this stage
the one message I want to convey is it
works or about to show you works in our
own case we've been using our own
students as guinea pigs if I can put it
that way we have an oli version of
introductory statistics we had students
who took it that way and students who
took at the traditional way the students
who took it in the technology based
version the oli version learned as well
or better than the students in the
traditional mode but they learned it in
half the time so better and faster are
pretty powerful things and we it's time
for us to exploit them this one adopted
fundamentally changes the role of the
faculty member doesn't get rid of the
faculty member remember the apple but it
changes the role that the faculty member
plays in fact it makes the faculty
member we think even more effective and
I will tell you that in engaging with
faculty as we have not only at our
institution but it large public
university systems
community colleges when the faculty
understand what this is about they
understand its power they get very
excited about it because they see it as
a way to improve their teaching and
believe it or not that's what faculty
really want to do they want to be the
best teachers that they can be well
don't take it from me take it from the
experts the students themselves have
been exposed to it the video you're
about to see comes from Santa Ana
community college it was shot by a
teacher we had nothing to do with this
we didn't Commission it the teacher who
was using it in an interested
instructors disses course sorry using
the oil oli technology decided to get
out a video camera and record her
students and their reactions to using
this technology and on our own
initiative sent it to us of course we're
happy to receive it and you'll see why
I've taken the course once before and I
did it through textbook and i have to
say that this time around doing it
through oli is completely different I
feel like I'm learning everything for
the first time I I guess I didn't have a
complete understanding of statistics
through the textbook but what I really
really like about it is the feedback
that you receive whether it's correct it
tells you why you're correct and if
you're incorrect it's it's red and tells
you why you're incorrect and it helps
you out to answer correctly the second
time are the examples in a textbook and
compared to the examples in L although I
it's pretty much the same except that
you actually able to do it just right
then and there and get the feedback so
it's in a way much more effective to
learn know what you're doing and
probably the next best part about it is
a you're actually able to do like math
programs like a mini tab in our case to
do the probe to do the problems and it
tells us how to do it step by step as
opposed to them on the book your kind of
left short on that so what I like about
the examples is I'm like in a regular
text book though they'll tell you what
it is you need to learn like they'll
give you a formula or something and then
they'll try to incorporate it into an
example but what all I does it kind of
gives you the example first and it
builds on what you already know I feel
like it makes me really understand the
material better because I'm going
outside of just learning you know and
memorizing the thing with Allah oh Allah
it gives the student autonomy to decide
how much help they require so it's not
as textbook at which talks down to you
you feel like you're overwhelmed with
all this information but at the same
time it's almost like you have an
instructor by your side to kind of nudge
you on
just I want to emphasize one thing as
you could infer from this oli refers to
a learning environment these are hole
courses statistics in this case what I
also talked about but not just
statistics where you students can learn
the material in an interactive way it's
not just taking course material and
putting it up on the web which many
other universities have done and that's
a great thing we applaud that but
students need more than just access to
online material they need a learning
environment an interactive environment
that's what oli is now to continue our
program i'm very pleased that we have
with us today the Under Secretary of
Education martha kanter with
responsibilities for higher education
within the department before coming to
Washington she served as chancellor of
foothill De Anza Community College in
California a longtime friend in a great
supporter of higher education thank you
for being with his Martha
I want to thank dr. Conan I'm so pleased
to be in the company of scholars here at
the cat in the house of representatives
because we are talking about education
and when you saw the students in that
video I think what all of our members of
Congress and all of us in the Department
of Education and every teacher in the
classroom wants is students that are
going to succeed and lead this next
generation so I'm really thrilled to be
part of this conversation about the
intersection of the learning sciences
and technology and how that intersection
which is brand new for us you know gosh
i was thinking back you know the
internet age happened and here we are
with learning sciences and technology to
improve instruction and figure out how
we can get more students across the
finish line for us in the Department of
Education and I think for all of us as
Americans a generation ago we were first
in the world and the number of students
who were attaining a minimum of vaca
laureate level degree and Beyond and
today were 16th were tied for 16th with
three other countries if you look at OE
CD education at a glance so we have a
huge challenge before us and dr. Khan
mentioned how these kinds of
technologies and the learning sciences
can help us really attack some of the
fallon jizz that we're facing and in
thinking about my few minutes of remarks
i pulled out two and it was amazing that
we sort of synchronized here two of
which what you know affect what happens
in pretty much every classroom across
America whether it's American higher
education k12 or even in our early
learning classrooms we have too many
students that are under prepared that's
sort of a significant national challenge
for us when we have and i'll just give
three little statistics off the top of
my head a third of children are not
ready for kindergarten we have only
seventy-five percent of students
graduating from high school and in some
communities around the country
way beyond that number unfortunately and
then when we look at higher education
when you look across all of our
institutions and we have islands of
excellence everywhere and you're you're
hearing from a couple of them at
Maryland and Carnegie Mellon very high
graduation rates low default rates all
the kinds of things you want to see that
help students know that this is a place
that I'm going to succeed in what we
look at is half of the students not
finishing within six years with a
minimum of an undergraduate degree so
you know when I think about going
forward and I look at how can we address
these kinds of pressing problems of
under preparation that every teacher
like myself when I started out you know
it was those students you couldn't reach
and why and is there a different way of
redesigning what you're doing to reach
them and get them on track and get them
knowing that even if it's hard I'm going
to do it anyway and even if I fail the
first time I'm going to be helped to
learn how to do it the second or the
third or the fourth time I think what
you're seeing here in this video is a
way to experiment with how to do a whole
lot better as a society than we've done
certainly in my 40 years in education
where we've had these declines now the
second challenge is about finishing what
we start and you know you talked about
the dropout rate and that was the second
challenge it's taking too long to
graduate and whether you consider
kindergarten readiness being a
graduation from zero to six year old kid
who's ready for first grade or whether
you think about high school graduation
or college graduation you know we're
losing too many students across that
trajectory and with the cost escalation
we've got to look for methods that are
going to reduce costs keep increasing
quality and deliver results for students
and Families so when people say you know
is college worth it should I just go for
a training program I say you know we
went Arne Duncan talks about this he
talks about college and career we want
students to have a vision for both in
their life and they may go into a
training program right out of high
school if they do graduate and with the
challenges that I mentioned
and that may be great but you know if
they're going to populate the kind of
economy we're going to need in this
country they're going to have to
continue on so I always say college and
career it's not to say that everyone
should get a baccalaureate degree or
advanced degree but if this nation is
going to be competitive in a global
economy we've got to do something to
help more students get through so the
getting through part is what I love when
I look at oli and a lot of the course
redesign work that that Chancellor
Kerwin has done at the University of
Maryland you know it's all about how do
we keep students engaged in the content
get that knowledge transfer it in the
best possible way give faculty the kind
of opportunity to do their best and
learn with us in these new technological
environments and learn about the
learning sciences we're learning
organizations in higher education I mean
we're never going to stop learning but
the bottom line is are my students going
to acquire that content are they going
to be ready for the next level of course
and are they going to stay on track to
finish and that's a big challenge for us
going forward so I think you know when
you see the the the date of the research
the evidence to say students are
finishing in a shorter amount of time if
we could get students at least
twenty-five percent hopefully fifty
percent more students finishing their
degrees in less time we will actually be
providing more into the economic base of
this country we're going to be
populating the two to three million jobs
and the economy that are unfilled today
we're going to sort of stop the tide of
the declining role that students are
playing in the economy because they're
not prepared for the jobs of the future
so I'm really inspired by the open
learning initiative i think it's
tremendously important secretary Duncan
and certainly President Obama you know
talked about open learning early on I
pulled out some statistics that the
first time the president talked about
this when he talked right after office
he I went with him to Macomb Community
College in in Michigan and he talked
about an online resource center and what
would it look like for the nation and it
was proposed as a vision what actually
happened was Congress appropriated two
billion
500 million of that was announced last
Friday by Vice President Biden and
that's an opportunity to do this kind of
thing apply these technologies in the
learning sciences to the Academy to the
academic programs whether it's a
community college or a university what
we want to see is much more
collaboration across the higher
education sectors so that they can take
advantage of these new ways that
students can learn and be much more
successful than they have in the past so
today you know the president proposed in
the last couple of weeks since the State
of the Union a couple of ideas that we
hope to see going forward one is called
a race to the top for higher education
focused on college affordability and
quality and completion so we are
reaching out to higher education and
policy makers to say what would this
look like to incentivize these kinds of
environments to increase student success
and what can we do in a shared
responsibility environment so that
states can play their part public
institutions can thrive private
institutions can lead the way and we can
work together so that institutions can
really get those graduation goals far
more accelerated than we have in this
last generation and we think that also
you know a fund which the president has
called first in the world he did say
that he would like to get America back
to be first in the world in the number
in the proportion of college graduates
across our nation when compared to other
countries so proposing a first in the
world competition would give professors
look that you'll hear from today and
others around the country the chance to
really innovate and take this kind of
work and double and triple the results
going forward that's what we want to see
we have too many students that are under
prepared at too many levels so it's very
exciting work in my opinion we've got a
couple of proposals that I think can be
really helpful to us going forward and
you know as educators let me just close
off by saying you know every having been
a teacher for many many years you know
every student learns differently and
every student has different needs and
different capacities and I call them
assets you know some students don't have
the kind of confidence we want to see in
our student population and what works
for one
student may hold another student back
and I think that's the beauty of what
the learning sciences can offer is that
differentiation so that students can
follow the learning environment and take
advantage of different ways of accessing
the knowledge so that they can really do
their best and use all of their talents
and skills in this regard so I want to
thank you dr. Khan for inviting me to
get up here and just give you a few
words from our perspective we're very
supportive of this kind of environment
we think open learned in open learning
initiative is leading the way we think
that a lot of this is stimulating and I
know this firsthand I just came back
from Ohio and I've been to a couple of
other places I think we have Rose marina
c4 just met with I think over 100
colleges the other day Allah it's
stimulating a lot of thinking about how
are we going to redesign the curriculum
for the 21st century so that we can
significantly increase on the one hand
the preparation of students and on the
other hand the acceleration so that they
can be successful and move on into the
workforce and into society to make their
contributions like we have done in our
time so thank you very much and look
forward to hearing dr. Kerwin
thank you very much Martha another
president to is at the White House at
that meeting I referred to before was
Britt Kerwin the Chancellor the
University of Maryland system he's a
longtime leader in the world of public
higher education the University of
Maryland system is probably doing the
best of any public university system
right now in what is a very challenging
environment and that's because of the
vision of Chancellor Kerwin he's been a
wonderful leader and a partner of ours
in oli thank you very much for being
here Britt Jared thank you so much i
very much appreciate the opportunity to
be part of this program in Martha I want
to thank you for all you're doing to
advance the cause of higher education
there in the department and working with
our president and Jared mentioned the
conversation we had with the President
and Jared and I were both talking about
oli course redesign the use of
technology learning science etc and you
could tell the president was you know
quite excited about this and so there I
am several weeks later listening to the
state of the union address and he talked
about this race to the top for higher
education which we mentioned at the at
the meeting and then he said and we've
got to get into course redesign and now
that probably passed over the head of
most Americans but Jared and I and all
who are in that room know where that
came from and I thought it was really
quite a quite a sense the example of you
know how how taken he is with with these
new ideas that can help promote teaching
and learning well Jared in Candace and
their colleagues at Carnegie Mellon have
of course developed this phenomenal
strategy within the very selective and
outstanding private university and the
question is can these ideas re you
used in the public sector so I just
wanted to give you a sense of what the
university system of maryland we've got
11 degree granting institutions to
regional higher education centers we got
a hundred and forty five thousand
students we've got selective public
universities open admissions public
universities and so it's a large complex
public university system and and I
hardly need to tell this audience that
public universities around the country
are facing unprecedented challenges
reductions in funding like we've never
seen before in American higher education
in many states fifty percent of the
public funding state funding has gone
away and this has led to quite frankly
unsustainable increases in tuition I
mean we have a tree have a we have a
model at the moment that is not serving
our nation well and that we have to find
other ways of doing things and I think
Jared your comments were so on the mark
that you know every other sector of
society has figured out how to use
technology to become more efficient more
effective and we in higher education who
have created the ideas that have led to
a lot of that technology have not done
that to the extent that the other
sectors have and that's why I'm so
excited about the work that's going on
in Carnegie Mellon and the work we're
doing at the University System of
Maryland because of these resource
challenges and these demands for greater
college completion and faster time to
degree we have made a huge investment in
this course redesign
new learning and teaching and learning
strategies we embarked upon this working
with the National Center for academic
transformation in Carol twig and then
we've been now joined in a partnership
with Carnegie Mellon through oli and you
know I'm proud to say that we now have
across the system this ring 12,000
students enrolled in redesigned open
learning like classroom classroom
settings the thing that has impressed me
so much about oli is that what what has
happened here is that they have brought
the cognitive scientists together with
the Disciplinary experts and that
combination of having of course you need
the Disciplinary experts but the
cognitive scientists to help design the
software that will enable and optimized
learning and retention in the students
that is the brilliance of to me of
what's going on at OU l so we have
faculty on our campus that are using
some of the oli modules in their courses
were engaged in a major research project
with several other university systems
using this statistics module that you
talked about to see the applicability in
a bit in big public settings and we have
a project underway with our online
University University of Maryland
University College where we are trying
to adopt the good help of Candice in her
colleagues trying to adopt adapt the oli
to a purely online setting so what I
I've just become a huge champion and
advocate for the work that oli and
others are doing in this area for a
number of reasons I think that there's
mounting evidence
now that these strategies after an
initial investment can lower the cost of
delivery of education and improve the
learning not just in a given course but
in follow-on courses that use those
basic basic introductory level courses
it isn't particularly effective in stem
courses where we of course as a nation
have a huge need to increase our
productivity with stem it promotes a
culture on the campuses of educational
innovation and so what we've learned
from this is this experience is that
that working with oli and with other
universities that you know we don't this
innovation that we're bringing into our
teaching and learning doesn't have to be
invented course by course in university
by University working together in
collaboration as we are we can
accelerate the process of bringing these
strategies into into our classrooms and
to our universities I'm a believer that
it is important to focus initially on
the low-hanging fruit I would call it
the large lower division stem courses i
think they are particularly well
designed for these strategies and they
are the important courses to focus on
because we lose so many students out of
the stem pipeline in the first two years
of college saw some statistics the other
day that only a third of the students
coming to our universities intending to
measure major in stem ever end up with a
stem degree so in this part because they
get turned off in those first two years
that's the magic of this of this
approach as we saw from those students
in the community college I think the I
just want to make that point that the
that that the another value
of this approach is it is right for the
students coming to our universities
today Jared and I grew up in a period
where we were very dutiful and we could
go in a large lecture hall and sit and
listen and take notes and you know very
passive under a setting but that's not
this generation of students they are you
know connect they have all this an
internet connection social networking
all of these gadgets and devices and so
multitasking being interconnected with
one of the working in teams that's what
works with this generation of students
if you haven't read yet a book called
the shallows by Nicholas Carr I urge you
to read it because he really captures
what's going on with this generation of
students the Millennials look I can call
them that and why these strategies are
so important and so effective for this
generation of students so let me just
conclude my comments by mentioning a few
factors that I think are very important
as universities begin to roll out and
think about embracing these strategies I
think it's very important for us to have
four universities it certainly worked
for us in the system to have the
availability of startup funds to invest
money to give to help faculty get
started down this path you've got to
have some seed money to invest to engage
the the faculty I think it's also
important as oli is the prime example
and icon for doing data gathering we
need data to show what's working and
what isn't working so we can have
continuous improvement with these
strategies I think it's also important
to understand that what with the faculty
that this has to be faculty driven but
administrative Lee
and encouraged so there's kind of a
push-pull here you just can't go to the
faculty and say here's what you're going
to do that isn't going to work but you
have to create some incentives and
motivation for getting faculty engaged
but what we have found is if you do that
you develop these champions these
faculty champions for this that then can
begin to infuse their enthusiasm across
the the institution and gain more and
more converts I just believe at the end
of the day faculty care deeply about the
learning their students attain in their
in their classes and when you can
demonstrate to them that these
strategies improve learning then you can
bring them along their hearts and minds
will follow because they will feel the
sense of responsibility to to to embrace
these strategies because of their proven
benefit now you know I recognize in
these difficult times there is no silver
bullet that no one thing is going to
solve our education problems higher
education problems with attainment and
cost etc but I'm telling you this is a
huge step forward the work coming out of
oli this this this of these new learning
strategies is a huge step forward and
we've got to find a way across the
country in higher education to embrace
this thinking and we are just so very
very proud to be a partner of with oli
and I want to thank Jared for his
leadership in moving the institution in
this direction and Candice for her
brilliance in bringing oli to the fore
and helping others learn from your great
experience so thank you very much
thank you very much Britt and now
finally you're going to get to hear from
the brains behind the operation ken
cating ER is professor of human-computer
interaction in the Carnegie Mellon
school computer science and co-director
that Pittsburgh science of learning
center and can distill is director of
the oli project colleagues who's going
first you are Candice so hello so we're
going to be talking about what we're
calling now the science and engineering
of learning so you've heard a bunch of
people refer to Carnegie Mellon zoom out
and say what is this thing everyone's
talking about so in a nutshell Carnegie
Mellon's open learning initiative is
scientifically based open really
important open online learning
environments designed to improve both
quality and productivity and higher
education now when we say scientifically
based I mean Brits right that the
science courses are a key area but that
doesn't mean that's not the science I'm
talking about the science I'm talking
about is the science of learning so I'm
just going to do a couple little quick
screenshots to show you what I mean
because one of the things we know from
the science of learning is that goal
directed practice and targeted feedback
support accelerate learning so when
we're designing oli activities we take
those kinds of ideas and incorporate
them into the learning design so this is
out of our engineering statics course
where we simply give the students a
problem asking them to some these three
forces and they're simply asked to type
in what's the direction and the
magnitude of the Sun so they can go
ahead and just type that in they get
this is the immediate feedback that the
students were talking about on the video
and they didn't know what to do so they
can ask for a hint and the system will
say if you need some help click here and
we'll help you rim help remind you what
the first step is so they click there
and resolve each of the forces into its
components and again the student can ask
for a hint if they're not sure how to do
that and the system walks them through a
hinting sequence that is scaffolding the
way we want them to be thinking when
they're
trying to solve the problem until they
get what we call the bottom out hint
which is the answer and we give them
that so they don't get stuck so they can
keep practicing and move on so I've sort
of fast forwarded here till the student
has finished this entire little mini
tutor and at the end it's a great that
you were able to do this but actually we
would hope that you could do this
without all that scaffolding and support
so click here in the system will
generate another problem when they click
their the graphical representations
change the problem changes all the hints
and feedback change this gives the
student virtually twenty four seven
support to in learning this process also
and aside from just doing tutoring there
are lots of different kinds of learning
activities for example when we're
teaching chemistry we teach it in the
context of a real world problem which is
the arsenic contamination of the water
supply in Bangladesh so the students are
just taught here stoichiometry learn it
they're put into the role of chemist to
solve a real-world problem and they're
given a well water sample from a well in
Bangladesh and ask is this water safe to
drink this connects the chemistry to the
real world and they're given the World
Health Organization statement about what
safe drinking water is and they can look
at the analysis in the virtual lab and
they can see how many moles of arsenic
are in that water but the World Health
Organization tells them how many
micrograms of arsenic are safe to drink
so in order to even answer that first
question they have to be able to do the
conversion from moles to micrograms per
liter and so what you can't see this
happening is as the students are
interacting with the environment not
only is the student getting immediate
feedback but the system is collecting
interaction level data about what the
student is doing and we're using that
data to drive inferences about what the
student is learning so the other person
who really needs that data just as Britt
was describing is the instructor so
rather than saying to your students oh I
wanted to say that one of the reasons
these continuous embedded assessments
are really important is because right
now what we do to try and figure out
what students know is we give them these
high-stakes single chance opportunities
to
and it has some real consequences this
is out of yesterday's New York Times
where it was talking about all these
placements exams we give students and
then place them into remedial education
and Martha can tell us the statistics of
if you get placed three semesters back
in remedial developmental math your
chances of ever getting out our what
seven percent so and this new study that
was done at the Columbia University's
teaching college has shown us that
actually these placement exams aren't
very effective or miss placing students
and so really actually harming students
actually being able to attain and what
Ken will talk about is how we can use
these environments to do much better
continuous embedded assessments that
will better give us a much better
picture of what the students knowledge
state is and how to how to support them
so rather than doing these high stakes
assessments to try and figure out what
the student knows and what we should do
with them what the instructor can do
instead is instead of saying take this
high-stakes assessment or work in this
paper and pencil environment they can
say work through module three of the oli
course and thus to end finish that
before ten o'clock Sunday night if we're
going to meet Monday morning so the
student works through the environment
they're getting all the support hints
and feedback so there are times more
productive and the system is collecting
the data for the instructor who then
Sunday night can look at the instructor
dashboard now this is a dashboard that's
taken out I took these screenshots out
of an actual statistics course that's
running at a community college right now
so this is real live data this is a
picture of this particular faculty
members class in their first module now
the bars tell the instructor where the
students are on those learning outcomes
that they value the students in the
green tells them those students are
doing well if we were going to give this
to a test today we would predict that
that student would nail that test on
that learning outcome the students in
the orange they're doing okay but
they're still struggling a bit the
students in red they're working but they
don't get it the students in gray well
those are the students that haven't done
enough work in our system for us to make
a reliable prediction the instructor can
also go because that large or outcome
relate measure
is a center and spread to the shape of a
distribution and choose the appropriate
measure in context that larger outcome
actually has a bunch of sub sub
knowledge and sub components so the
instructor can also click over to this
side and say what are the component
knowledge that the students need that
they're struggling with bitters not
allowing them to support them to achieve
that outcome and so the instructor can
click in and see who are those students
that are those dots I've put a block
over it because as I said this is a real
class and they can also look at for
certain sub skills like computing the
median what kinds of activities of the
students doing in the course that are
struck they're struggling with and this
is just a sample activity now you'll
notice that the activities in the course
are not here's a bunch of numbers
compute the median we don't give you
that activity 20 times we give the
students activities embedded in multiple
different tasks and concepts and so
multiple times over the course in doing
many different things they'll have to
compute the median and we're looking at
how well they can compute the median
each one of those contexts and so what
are the affordances of the technology of
online technology when you ask most
people will say one of these three
things the first thing they'll say is
right there in the middle convenience
that students can take learning anytime
anyplace the other thing some people
might say is what's represented over
here which is you can show them things
and do things that you can't do in the
concrete world you can show the
molecular simulations or you can have
them build a bridge and he'll crush
without killing a bunch of people or the
connectivity piece which is what Britt
was talking about with the online
environments we could have students
connecting with students students
connecting with experts students
connecting with material and all of
these three things are great the but
they're not the most powerful thing
about these environments the most
powerful thing about these environments
are what Google has figured out it's
what netflix has figured out it's what
amazon has figured out the most powerful
thing about these environments is not
just pushing information out but using
them as big data collectors to bring the
information in and what Google and
Amazon
Netflix are using it for us to
understand you better as a consumer or
to understand consumers better what we
want to use that information for us to
understand you better as a learner so we
can serve you better as a learner and
also understand better about learners in
general now Ken I'm going to turn over
to Ken because he's going to talk about
how we use this data to understand
better about learners in general I want
to step back a second and address a
question that X actually Chancellor
Kerwin brought up which I'm sure you've
all thought of this question before Y as
science and technology made such
incredible advances in things like
medicine and transportation but done so
little for for education and I want to
suggest that one of the root causes is
that our experiment beings we learn and
we experience learning but what we
experience is just that thin sliver of
what's actually happening in our minds
what we know about our own learning is
this tip of the iceberg here and what's
really going on when we learn is much
bigger and it's much more complex and
because we have this impression that we
understand learning we are our decisions
that we make as educators and policies
are biased by just a teeny bit of what's
really going on well the opportunity for
science and technology is to understand
what's going on underneath the surface
there and make decisions that are much
more informed by a deep understanding of
what's going on so we have to get past
this notion that we know what we know we
have to accept that we don't know what
we know and we don't really know what
what what it is we're learning because a
lot of it happens implicitly so I want
to make that a little bit more concrete
by taking an example some from some
early work that I did as we were
building this algebra intelligent
tutoring system that's now in use across
the country and it was one of our early
success cases and it involves an end
vestigation into what what's hard for
beginning algebra students about algebra
what kind of problems do they have
difficulty with and you see examples of
three different kinds of problems here
and now when I did this study I was
curious why those story problems have
such a reputation of being so difficult
and in fact when we asked math educators
and teachers what do they think are the
hardest problems they say either the
story or words that word problems are
going to be the hardest we ran a number
of studies where we looked at the actual
performance of students and I was quite
shocked we have replicated this many
times to find that in fact that was
wrong that in fact the students were
having most difficulty with the
equations these beginning algebra
students in essence were struggling with
algebra as a second language in any of
you have tried to acquire a second
language you know how long it takes lots
of repetition and what's a little bit
striking about this is that even though
these algebra teachers who by the way
were the worst at making the correct
prediction the ones who actually teach
this they've learned it they somehow
haven't tracked all that work their
brain was doing underneath the surface
to acquire the language of algebra and
we think this is going on all over the
place and that's why it's so important
that we have data to guide what we're
doing so president Cohen mentioned our
Pittsburgh science of learning center
which we call learn lab for short and
we're we're trying to in that center
take advantage of these fielded
technology systems like this algebra
intelligent tutoring system the oli
courses all of which are being used
across the country and in some cases
across the world to do what we call
basic research at scale so there's tons
of learning science research out in the
literature in schools of education and
psychology a lot of that gets done in
the laboratory what we want to do is use
this opportunity of the technology to be
able to do laboratory quality studies
out in the real world and we've been
enabling that through the center since
2004 one of the things that we're doing
is collecting a lot of data I guess I'm
the guy who's showing you all the
professor de kind of graphs here but
I want to use this to once again
illustrate the complexity of the
learning process now data shop is an
open and free data repository I believe
it's the largest open data repository of
educational technology in the world and
and researchers can go and study this
data but I want to zoom in on one of
these learning curves now this is a
learning curve of students working in a
geometry unit about the area of
geometric figures and the y-axis here is
their error rate average cost all the
participating students as they get
opportunities to practice and if you
look at that graph does that look like a
learning curve is there learning going
on it doesn't look like there's learning
going on if we look at learning at the
level of like our standards at the k-12
this is what we would see the complexity
is not reflected at that level if we
take exactly the same data and graph it
in terms of the specific skills that are
being involved and count the
opportunities to practice those we now
get a smooth learning curve as
represented in the red line and we can
fit statistical models to that that make
accurate predictions of student learners
and that's represented in the blue line
so we can see learning at this skill
component level and we can use the
technology to help us understand it more
deep in a more detailed way now many
researchers have been doing this sort of
thing it's often called cognitive task
analysis Richard Clarke at the
University of Southern California's then
a number of studies demonstrating that
this kind of detailed analysis can
dramatically improve courses and for
example we've applied this in all I one
of the tough topics in the chemistry
courses on equilibrium and students were
about twenty percent correct on items in
that course initially and applying these
techniques to that area involved a lot
of analysis and some redesign of the
course that then resulted in a large
increment improvement on student
performance in that area now the what
the future holds is a new opportunity
for us to do that kind of intensive
analysis which is which is often
involves a lot of human effort to
accelerate and enhance it through the
educational technology data and we're
starting to leverage that data shop
crowd sourcing techniques machine
learning techniques to essentially have
humans and machines look at the
individual learning curves for alleged
skill components and identify ones that
may not actually be showing learning
that are indicators that we can make an
improvement there that we've got
something wrong about the nature of
student learning and we can go zero in
on that and improve the course Candice
mentioned that one of the great
opportunities here is because these
technologies are collecting data
constantly you know teachers not in a
situation where where he or she needs to
wait until the spring or maybe even next
year before the state test results come
out to have good information about where
students stand we can get that
information and we've demonstrated that
it's very accurate this is data from a
system that was used used in
Massachusetts predicting the end of year
eighth-grade math M cast test score very
accurately so I don't know that we're at
the stage where we can say we'll throw
out that standardized test but in some
sense we're getting the information we
need from the online technology and
we're getting it now when teachers can
react to it so the other thing I wanted
to emphasize is it's not just complexity
of learning but complexity of
instruction that's important and often
in our debates about education we talk
as though there are two alternatives for
teaching there's some back to the basics
kind of approach and versus some reform
reproach like phonetics in in reading
verses whole a language whole word
reading or math has basic skills versus
more constructivist more deep thinking
this really does not well characterized
with a complexity of instruction there's
much more than these two options and if
there's tons of you know volumes of work
that's been done here are just three
reports that get at many many different
issues there are things like should we
mass practice or distributed over time
or maybe adaptively change the the
distance between practice opportunities
as technology
geez can do but there's many more
dimensions studying examples versus
tests on problems versus some mix and
these dimensions combined with each
other and this keeps going and going and
in fact there are thousands of options
for instructional choice and herein is a
huge opportunity for the science of
learning to understand what works best
and as Martha Kanter was saying earlier
what works best for which students in
which courses at which time the problem
is huge the challenge is huge but the
opportunity is great and I think we're
on our way to tackle that opportunity
one of the things learn labs been doing
is facilitating these laboratory quality
studies within real classes and I've
done many of those studies one
interesting one in stem courses we found
that it's often better to have students
provide explanations for worked out
solutions of problems rather than the
teachers provide those explanations the
students learn more from attempting to
generate explanations than from
receiving them but once again it's not a
one-size-fits-all we've also shown in
other contexts that this strategy is
actually rather inefficient in certain
language learning contexts for instance
so too to summarize we have a contrast
here between the way we often have
thought about design of courses in the
past which is more intuitive it's
usually isolated a single professor is
creating a new course and then we're
basically flying blind as we deliver it
and often have a kind of
one-size-fits-all oversimplification in
that course and the opportunity with
with oli and these new approaches is to
have a more evidence-based approach to
have a connected development team
working together as Chancellor Kerwin
said have cognitive scientists working
with the course developers together to
have that be data-driven in the many
different loops we've talked about and
to really manage this complexity that
I've tried to illustrate here and it
really does make a difference we can use
science and technology to improve
assessment make it more continuous
timely and accurate
increase outcomes accelerate learning as
in the statistics example you've heard
about and produce these virtuous cycles
of improvement so let me close with a
quote from Herbert Simon who's a Nobel
laureate from Carnegie Mellon who said
improvement in post-secondary education
will require converting teaching from a
solo sport to a community-based research
activity thank you